vitesse ok maintenant maintenant tourne la direction et vole vole
vers les vaisseaux change de
direction ce n'est pas trop rapide pour toi non
non c'est une bonne vitesse c'est une bonne
vitesse bonne vitesse pour un plan large
ouais m
je veux dire ok ce n'est pas bon ce n'est pas un bon
arrêt  enregistrement de si nous pouvions le faire
maintenant,
allez-y un peu plus loin, puis
tournez l'hélicoptère vers la gauche quand
ils sont tous alignés, tous les navires sont
alignés,
tournez à gauche maintenant, je suppose que d'accord, c'est juste
bien, ils sont tous  tous alignés
devant chacun devant l'
autre
un peu plus à droite
ouais d'accord ouais
[Musique]
ouais
je peux voir la luminance
bouger
ok euh je suggère qu'on recommence parce que
ouais ok arrête d'enregistrer on pourrait juste se
retourner  et
[Applaudissements]
FL, je vais suivre la
route,
ok
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Rires] [
Musique] d'ici [
Musique]
hé ok, nous devrions faire quelques
plans plus rapprochés des bateaux, je pense que celui-là,
euh,  de ce côté aussi on
devrait le refaire ouais ouais l'inverse
ouais retourne-toi tu fais ça
[Musique]
ouais bas plus
bas
[Rires]
ok
ok je pense que ça aurait été
merveilleux si on avait eu quelques mètres plus bas
pendant
ouais là un petit peu  de flare juste
un peu à droite euh
[Musique]
donc j'aime bien le bateau ici tout
seul ok eh bien fais le tour, fais le tour à
droite du bateau suivant oh
[Applaudissements]
ok
je et bien je ne sais pas  ce que tu
regardes ok qu'est ce que ok arrête juste d'enregistrer
si on se dirige tout droit vers celui-là, euh
celui
que
tu
vas à droite de
nous juste à droite pas très loin juste
très près à
droite
on fait une main gauche on fait un cercle  autour du
B à deux les deux jusqu'à la
fin [Musique] prenez de très gros plans depuis le
bateau non oui je le ferai, je ferai le tour
du
cercle [Musique] [Rires]
[Musique]
parce que
ce n'est pas bon maintenant
nous pouvons voir le  ligne donc ce n'est pas
bon bien tu veux tu veux
redémarrer sur l'
hélicoptère quelle ligne vois-tu je sais que
nous avons juste des interférences sur l'
image non nous
ne devrions pas aller
trop vite à gauche du navire au-dessus de celui-ci  pour
toi, nous pourrions en faire un de plus ouais, un de plus un
peu plus
lent,
je peux, ce n'est pas fermé mais d'accord
[Rires]
mets
-le à
proximité,
allez pour ne pas avoir le sable qui monte, je
pense que
pour
[Musique]
euh, d'accord ouais ouais, je  Je suis
content, euh, d'
avoir
celui-là, ce qui serait bien,
c'est peut-être de
[Musique]
de [
Rires]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
D plus bas en cercle autour de celui qui
a été coupé
[Musique] [
Rires]
ok merde
[Musique]
merde
c'est bien  nous devons recommencer
mais une autre
façon de soulever de l'acier sur le
camion ne sert à rien, il suffit d'
aller directement au soleil, ce n'est pas trop de
chair, c'est moi, nous
avons un peu trop de poussière pour
arrêter
[Rires]
nous le recommençons pour moi, ok, continuez
faire un cercle comme ça, un autre
autre cercle
autour de
[Rires],
c'est bon, [ __ ], euh
ok, pouvez-vous juste garder un autre cercle
autour s'il vous plaît et je vais le faire avec un
angle légèrement plus large, je vais le recadrer
à 40
mil
ici
[Rires]
hé, ils  Je vais juste continuer à
venir pour mettre AIT en mettant un peu d'
acier sur le
camion
et pensez-vous
qu'à tout moment vous pourriez bien, je pense que
c'est assez oui ouais, pas encore assez,
c'est arrêter d'enregistrer mais il y a une
chose que nous  je pourrais faire c'est encore prendre le
le de cette hauteur tu sais le
je
tu l'as là-bas dans la même
perspective mettre l'acier sur le
camion ce n'est pas mal d'
ailleurs laisse-le
partir
bien euh
oh on devrait avoir CAU ça  oh je veux dire ça
aurait pu être
[Musique]
C ok les gars eh bien
euh
suggestions
[Rires]
avant
pour
ni H ils appellent les chameaux les navires du
désert ouais mais c'est dommage qu'ils se soient
envolés, ils sont partis c'était sympa hein
c'était sympa ça  c'était sympa j'ai payé beaucoup d'
argent pour avoir ces chameaux je ne te l'ai pas dit
mais j'ai payé beaucoup d'argent pour avoir
ces
chameaux que tu as coupés ouais ouais ouais ok
allons-y,
ce serait assez bas tu sais une
grue une grue  le mouvement d'une caméra que vous
connaissez monte, monte et monte,
[Musique], hé,
tu
photographies, oui
est-ce que celui-ci
était trop rapide
de toute façon,
oui hé, arrête d'enregistrer
depuis
[Rires]
il
moi
est une
ombre à
droite, ils vont y aller  dehors
maintenant peut-être qu'il est un peu trop tard pour ce
plan, j'ai trop d'ombre
maintenant
euh
tu
coupes on ne t'entend pas
I
oh